[Music]
can take one Guinness World Record which
is obviously a massive achievement but
to take another nine that says something
you're not going away
and guess what I'm not going away
I'm Terry turbo Burrows the fastest
window cleaner in the world
when I found out there was a world
record I knew I wanted to break it I had
to work out the maths the movements the
training it's going to need I thought
yeah I can do that Bring It On
when I first started out my uncle Alfie
taught me how to use the squeegee an
applicator and they would start wetting
up with the right end with the
applicator and then switch it over and
squeezing it off and I thought why not
just wet it up
do that Terry had a talent and he
wondered where it might take him
every day I get up about 7 30.
I come down and make myself some coffees
probably about three or four
I'll do a bit of gaming and then my
regime starts welcome to the training
camp
I got myself a window and fixed it on
the back of the garden shed and I was
practicing away and what was hilarious
about all this was her neighbor mowing
the lawn and be looking at me thinking
why is he cleaning that window over and
over again but the window don't go
through anywhere it doesn't see anything
what is he doing
Terry entered his first competition aged
40. I remember my first major
competition was in France it was huge it
was like an arena for the winter
cleaning competition I was absolutely
bowled over and then all of a sudden
this person comes up to me they're
carrying the Union Jack for me I thought
oh my God this is like the Olympics this
is amazing
in those eight to nine seconds you've
got to be as fast as you can you've got
five moves per window and wipe the seal
clean and you've got to keep all that
together just in those few seconds it's
nuts Terry took home the trophy and the
next one and the next one well actually
he won the next 15 competitions he
entered and he's not giving up anytime
soon what you do is you start from the
top here go down like this and all the
time your legs moved over into position
and uh that is basically it
don't look at that bit
It's My Life passion you've got to be
tunnel visioned which I have been and
not swayed one iota I plan to go out the
world
as the fastest window cleaner and on the
planet so if any aliens are up there
um that'll be cool you come down and
take me on
[Music]
me dip you in my bucket and give you a
squeeze would you let me call me ladder
oh you're such a tease let me swing you
in my cradle begging you please let me
dip you in your bucket of love
see you every day but you won't buy I
wonder if you know it's me way up in the
sky all the fellas on the site